des sirènes retentissent dans les rues
de kiev
à 7h ce matin la capitale ukrainienne se
réveille en état d' alerte
de nombreux habitants tentent de fuir en
voiture
d'autres se réfugient dans le métro
je suis paniqué effrayée je ne sais pas
vers qui on peut se tourner c'est
effrayant
on espère que le métro va nous sauver
parce que ces souterrains
se protéger d'éventuels bombardements au
sud de la capitale au moins deux
explosions ont retenti tôt ce matin à la
hâte ses habitants ont fait leurs
valises
il ya eu des explosions puis les sirènes
comme on ne savait pas vraiment ce
qu'elle signifiait c'était effrayant
des ménages d'une rue à l'autre parce
que je vivais séparément de mes parents
et maintenant avec ce qui se passe je
veux aller vivre chez eux devant les
magasins et les pharmacies les files
d'attentes s'allongent sans savoir ce
qui les attend dans les prochains jours
les ukrainiens font des réserves par
précaution j'ai fait des courses par
peur de trouver les magasins ville de
demain je fais des provisions
une capitale en alerte dans une vidéo
amateur le maire de kiev s'est adressé
aux habitants
qui vivent un autre maire a expliqué
qu'il ne faut pas paniquer mais quand
même il faut préparer une petite valise
avec des papiers de l'argent et de l'eau
potable des habitants sur leurs gardes
craignant de faire face bientôt à une
attaque de grande ampleur